oh oh it's this one oh it's our old
friend uh this is a fun one
oh good i'm glad i'm a prop a joke's on
me hey uh hey
wade come here i have an idea he's never
gonna see it coming
i'm the hunter
[Laughter]
okay grab one of those okay all right
now stand side by side okay okay all
right and then when he comes when he
comes around that corner if you hit
control and you move forward we'll
slowly move towards him and his like
elden ring instincts will kick in and
he'll want to right right right it's
like two great shields yeah exactly yeah
exactly all right there he is three two
one guys
oh
oh yeah triple here it comes big cans
yeah what are you going to do fire a
grenade
right at your feet
oh
what the hell
hey bob
you guys are
wizards
yeah we figured a couple of things out
yeah yeah we're pretty good oh
oh perfect
oh but now three of you do it
oh who is that what are you doing i
pressed f3 to get unstuck
where did that lead me back to you
okay i'll go stand in the corner
okay okay
[Laughter]
easy there champion
he's there slugger are you in this room
maybe no you're outside
you don't know that
[Laughter]
you do me
what's going on out there
what's going on
something fun happening
[ __ ] again
hey i'm stuck back into the spawn room
that other pro stress f3 to get out of
the way oh can you tell which room i
kept screwing up
i don't know man i'm i'm not moving
around i'm chilling
it's your worst nightmare
say again it's your
it's your worst nightmare
a room where my genius okay
goodbye
where my genius can unfold like uh
i heard a taunt in here ah my genius yo
it's intimidating forces you to run
at high speeds
my ultimate strategy
yes yes see yourself lost to madness
hoping praying for a moment to see about
what you can't see cause your eyes
betray you i'm not gonna lie i thought
bob was the hunter because i kept
appearing right in front of the hunter
but i guess that was uh oh that was me
i was just able to see the activities of
that interaction there's no way you're
still in that room
i have not moved
the wonders of my mind
did you have the melon
no no what was that
you're one of these
unless you're still one of these no no
silly he's one of something
oh is he
i'll find you
even if it takes me off
your foolishness flailing like a maniac
will
the way it's happening
i feel your mind unraveling
cute
are you
are you are you a chair wait wait give
up just too soon
[Laughter]
but you don't know which one
i was a cactus on the shelves that you
were shooting the [ __ ] out of
oh i thought they were all one unit
idiot i think i shot one of the cacti
and then yeah whatever whatever all
right boys
okay okay okay
oh [ __ ] oh
ow i cut myself mark i cut myself on a
glass bottle can you come on no don't go
there no no no no
no
i'm thinking that there's something in
this room
[Music]
oh no why
you want a sip
oh come here
come here let me get some of that
oh wait i see what's going on here no
no look
[Laughter]
oh sad violin 2014. sorry man sorry man
this is a week oh it would have been
great if bob didn't
yeah it would be really good if i didn't
ruin that he really tried to distract me
from that room
what was that
that's how it stays in real life
do it again
the choo choo choo choose these these
[Laughter]
what a believable sneeze thank you
i can't believe he sneezed like that my
acting or resume speaks for itself
oh yeah bob oh yeah
right i am licking the lollipop that you
have served
hmm
okay bob i gotta stop spectating you if
you're gonna keep playing copyrighted
music sorry uh this is just random i
didn't look at this door stop you from
opening the door
what
yeah you shoulda that would have been a
great strategy all right bob martin
there's probably another one with cool
stuff in it you should probably go away
okay
fine
that was easy
i just want you know you might want to
yeah you don't want to check the room
you were just in
oh no come on
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
what the hell did that just do i
i don't know did you get a beyblade no
no
let it rip
oh you think i'm between the desks i see
what's going on oh
that would make sense i don't know
the only thing he doesn't know is that
there's a secret compartment
what was that it's a hidden drawer
uh you know if you hit alt f4 on one of
the drawers you could open them on the
desk mark
he'll never find you
i'll play
he didn't see it did he
[Laughter]
well that's about right
it ended the only way it could mm-hmm
it does all right buckaroos get your
props tightened and buckle up the
graphics on level four
yes who no
oh man oh i can't fit through that oh no
i dang it
why didn't you guys both turn into
characters from the 90s
which character though
the good ones
oh
here i go propping again i if i beat you
by staying in the same room again
no stranger
i did not have my eyes on the timer
on my taunt i have to be honest
holy [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] okay now
now you'll never find me
now i'm gone and tiny like an [ __ ]
who's
just like an [ __ ] you wanna see a
secret shawn
yeah
it was me the whole time wait oh no i
tried to press f3 and it didn't work
out if you're not stuck the game tells
you you're not stuck
i was so happy it was good
okay
i wouldn't be one of them
[Laughter]
i think i open up the wrong room
see if it opens up to a different room
this time why does the door open the
opposite way
i don't know i thought it would block it
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay i'll try again
oh it's a void it's the darkness inside
what the [ __ ] oh yes there you go
i can see through the wall here that's
cool
you'll never open
where'd you go bob
you picked me up
come on man why you guys touch all the
lamps
go into the first room on the right and
be anything in there and i'll let you go
this one
yeah
sorry we're trying to go somewhere
excuse me excuse me i need to get in
here excuse me hang on
wait he actually got bought you yeah i
changed uh to a bookshelf cause i was
gonna be like pull the right book you'll
get in and then
then bob you know
are you still a lamp
what happened
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
it worked
or we're not who's blocking this doorway
why god i literally freeze every time i
try a door
well don't don't wait stop i hear
footsteps but don't
don't
close that door oh my god put it down
put it that way and not let me put it
down oh
oh oh no you're good you're good you're
good
jesus christ
combination of noises that had happened
eight years
there's somebody in here
no
no no no
no no
who will die
i didn't watch my health so one of those
might have worked
[Laughter]
okay cool
you guys are all settled
everything's fine don't worry it's
totally fine
well something looks a little weird in
this corner
haunt sound
marker mark is this you
uh you
no
oh it was actually
like all good i'm murdering someone else
[Laughter]
all right oh wow oh all right back here
again we're gonna we're gonna
boop one two three one of these
you it's you isn't it
uh
come on would you like something from
inside of me open up if you want to hang
on it's a complicated procedure hang on
i've i'm doing some hooks yeah and some
latch don't look over to your right
[Laughter]
i know this trick bob i play i made this
trick
you may have discovered this trick but i
was bored in it
oh really did that really work here do
you need a
do you need a lamp
that really that really actually all the
way works i can't turn into anything
else oh i can thanks uh you're welcome
goodbye
all right bob back wait you're playing
the other table stuck in here
wait hang on
oh good lord
[Laughter]
please
hey how you doing
you go in there
you stand there you stay inside oh
hey buddy
[Laughter]
wow
good stuff i can't believe you didn't
see me as the big green thing the first
i guess you weren't watching your health
i guess you weren't telling the true
truth he shot you
i know
what a ding
this is not it this is not the play on
an absolute broseph you know
you said it migo
all right get your taints in check
looking good
i feel like i'm slightly higher than i
should be
listen listen to that beautiful taunting
you want to go check that out
[Laughter]
keep running there you go
oh god no oh god oh wait wait wait wait
wait wait
uh hold on hold on i'm stuck okay
whoa i haven't been in this room before
excuse me
shut up me
oh my god
[Laughter]
wait that is just the longest time man
oh i'm frozen you got a second you can
get out of there if you want okay good
you did oh my god good job wade these
doors
no
like you again what do you sound like a
swarm of bees no no no no
[Music]
stop
[ __ ] god
[Laughter]
i feel like you should have been found
by now are you one of these
oh i thought they'd explode i guess not
[Laughter]
oh my god come on
can you find me can you
um
right uh i can't i can't see below me am
i am i on something
yeah i guess i must be stuck
no i just i might be i was gonna help
nope
yes sir i'll watch your rear only we
knew where people are stuck go
oh
[Laughter]
well you must be stuck
[Laughter]
oh well hey no i died what i shot a hole
in that baby and then i teleported and
then the baby went
away god
is that this room or the other room
what the [ __ ] let me in
oh i haven't heard that in a while
oh my god whoa dude easy shoving around
the whole everything here
yeah i gotta find you
you're one of these
oh
he didn't get a cool prank wade
uh that would have been so epic it would
have been yeah
let me see if i can oh this is not
working the way i intended one of these
dogs i believe in you
yeah can you give me an assist
yeah it's going the opposite direction
somehow no that's actually you know what
yeah no that'll work that'll work and
i'm
oh
god you're you know what you know
what'll really sell this what you don't
really sell this yes
oh why would you do that
don't move don't move don't move don't
move don't move don't move don't move
don't move
you two need a moment
i need to give you a moment
oh god no
what is happening hang on wait a minute
oh i almost had it
and i thought you figure yourselves out
wait wait what do you think i am just
out of curiosity hate can underneath him
okay good good yeah no it's working
working as intended
oh [ __ ] uh hang on thank you that's like
sean you guys do your thing
you're going to give up oh you pansy
yeah pansy right
what a big baby if you want me to shoot
i can't oh no
oh are we are we all becoming this
[Music]
hang on i can help you mark don't worry
yep yep that's open is this helping
that's helping ass open
uh well we're not done we're not don't
look don't look don't look mark do it
don't
you don't even know your computer
systems i don't that's why they're
always broken you see i try to look at
the modem and i try to plug everything
in and press the buttons on the monitor
you guys are stupid no no no no no no no
no no no god okay i'm gonna go in here
and count to five give you guys a minute
okay one
two mark i think this is the play this
is the play this is this is the play man
it's the play it's the play ah
very good we're ready mark
no thank you
what do you like whoa
easy that's that's my sister your
manhandling
pokemon that hurt
it hurts this time
how'd you know it was me man how'd you
know how did you know okay props don't
worry i'm gonna bring you home on your
shelves okay all right well all right
he's cheating with his melons over there
not ever gonna find bob you're not
literally never gonna find bob
literally not ever no shopping
[Music]
go away come back move to a different
house and you'd still never find them
yeah what's it like to have no hope man
what's it like
uh it's like having no hair
that's you that's you right now
you're just cutting down you're just
you're just well accepting your fate i
think i think that was a start up sound
though just pack a suitcase
just check your bag with the airline and
then never see it again wade
just
do it
he's a snoopy so close you looked right
at me
alas
great job everybody
good job guys that round the only way it
deserved to
everybody loses
[Music]
you